what's some Brian welcome back Brian if
you're driving you should not be
cheering taggi bits but maybe your other
red lights
hopefully okay let's um let's actually
play my favorite black opening that's
one of the most aggressive responses to
e4 this opening is laced with with traps
so many ways what can go wrong yeah this
is already I mean I could force a draw
halberd welcome back it was actually a
fascinating line so there's a few
different King moves but the main point
of this whole opening is to make white
spend a lot of time trying to decide
where to go
that's funny White was trying to play
safely with d3
I was just Castle it's been a while
since I've actually looked at this and
now it's time to think
like take some Queen h4 like Kings just
I need the Kings only develop piece it's
such a funny position everything else
the king I just flavor he ate this is
just winning checkmate
yeah this is why this is my favorite
opening there's so many fun lines when
the King just gets ripped from its
shelter but it's a it's a highly dubious
opening not the type of opening that you
want to play in like professional events
I'm putting on line blitz does worse
yeah maybe maybe YouTube would enjoy
that thanks for thanks for reminding me
you too people hope you enjoyed this
scheme forcing my opponent to develop
the king yeah this is uh I mean this
just to show the pot can't take because
the Queen
there's a pin if the King takes like
stockfish doesn't entirely know what's
going on here it just says it's about
equal there might be some perpetual but
so hope it's just a hilarious position
because weight has everything back the
kings in the center but weights up to
pieces
thank you Babson I'm sure there's a lot
of analysis that can be done
yeah like Queen h4 there's this
interesting little Queen h5 and takes
there's a pin and then it's still really
complicated anyway yeah YouTube people
say hi to twitch people and vice versa
and I'll see you in the future